غضب عارم في الشوارع وانشقاقات داخل
الحكومه انضم اليها سياسيون وقاده في
الشرطه والجيش والحكومه تاييدا طبعا
لاصوات المتظاهرين ضد مشروع نتنياهو
القضائي الاضرابات عمت المدن الاسرائيليه
وشلت الحياه الاقتصاديه لاسيما ايضا هذه
الاضرابات امتدت الى البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الاسرائيليه في خارج البلاد حيث تضامنت
سفارات تل ابيب بعده دول مع المحتاجين
واعلنوا اضرابهم وعلى راس هذه السفارات
السفاره الاسرائيليه في واشنطن لنعد الى
الداخل مشاهدينا ومقابل هذه التظاهرات
الرافضه لمشروع نتنياهو خرجت اخرى مضاده
حين دعا وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
لتمار بن غفيره انصاره الى تنظيم مظاهرات
مضاده في القدس تحديدا وتاييدا لتلك
الدعوات ناشد وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
رئيس حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه انصاره الى
توجه ايضا للقدس مشيرا الى ان مسار
الاصلاح ومسار الاصلاح النظام القضائي
طبعا وتعزيز الديمقراطيه يجب ان لا يتوقف
وفق قوله
[موسيقى]
ايها الرفاق اصلاح النظام القضائي وتعزيز
الديمقراطيه يجب الا يتوقف تحت اي ظرف نحن
الاغلبيه ويجب ان لا نستسلم للعنف والفوضى
والرفض نحن الاغلبيه لنجعل صوتنا مسموعا
سنلتقي الليله في القدس امام الكنيست
ساكون هناك